Okay so we are going to go ahead and restructure this program
a little bit to use our new secure functions. You can see
I've, I've got them here. The three functions that we were working
on in those quizzes. Let's go ahead and use those. So the first
thing that we want to do is we are not going to
store these visits in a variable called visits anymore we are going to
call it visit cookie dough. Equal get visits. 'Kay. And we're also,
we're going to make a new variable for actual visits count. I'm just going to
give by default, be zero. And then we say if visits,
cookie val, basically if it's not none because get will return
none if that cookie doesn't exist at all. Which is whats
going to happen if the users never been to us. We're going
to run our check secure valve on this visit cookie stir.
I renamed this variable to visit cookie stir and the result
of that we're going to store in cookie val and remember
if cookie val remember that function returns none if it wasn't valid.
If cookie val visits equals int. Cookie Val. So we
set visits to zero by default, we look up our cookie.
If we have a cookie at all. We try to decode
it using Check Secure Val, and if we got a result
back from that. That's our valid result, we convert it
to an integer and we sort in visits. So visits is.
is either zero or what we got in the cookie. We
don't need to check Any more if its a digit because
we're going to assume its valid so we're going to say visits
plus equals one because know we know its valid, nobody's tampered with it.
This integer should have worked. Now we need to update our new our
new cookie value. So we call our make secure val function. We gotta
convert visits to a string before you send that in and then we
are going to send that to our header. Okay, so we made these
changes, let's go to our browser and give it a try. So we're
in our browser, reload our page. The physi cookie has whatever we left
in it before 10,001 or something which isn't going to be
valid because there's no hash. So we reload the page and
we start seeing our counter, but you can see our, our
feature's working now. You can, you can see our counter's working.
If we look at our cookie, you can see it now
stores the number. And it has the hash. Notice it's got
a pipe here, I notice a little snafu with Google app
engine when I was working on this where a comma and
a cookie had some special meaning so I changed our
function to use the pipe character instead of a comma
because I was getting a bug. Here are my cookie
str didn't have anything after the comma. So, I have switched
from commas to pipes and that is what we will
use for the rest of the lesson. Back to the
browser. We can see that we, we have this cookie.
If we were to mangle this cookie a bit, by saying
this equals 10,001 and then we will use this same hash like this. 10,001
and reload the page. It resets us back to one. Because our cookie wasn't valid,
or at least the number and the cookie didn't match the hat, match the
hash. So because the check secure val failed, we reset visits back to zero. Or,
actually what we, we never set it to what its true value is.